can you steel man the arguments for the
various ways omicron might have evolved
from a 2020 strain without being noticed
by the medical community that has been
sequencing as many variants as they find
to the naive engineered seems like a
possibility but i would like to hear
other natural evolutionary solutions to
the problem
yeah so the answer is kind of a yes and
no i think we can steel man the general
category i do want to say i think i said
something last week uh that i wanted to
correct this week i think i suggested
that the spike in the omicron variant
doesn't have
uh mutations doesn't have alterations
mutations is actually the wrong term
because those mutations are then um
either selected or not but yeah mutation
has been a confusing term here but
nonetheless there are something like 30
alterations to the spike protein that
makes a lot more sense
that's much more in keeping with what
that seems to be the most quickly
evolving part of
the virus on the other hand actually
zach would you show what we've got here
is somebody has put together a
time-lapse animation of the phylogeny of
different strains and i should just say
to our audience
molecular phylogenetics has never been
our bag particularly we've been in and
around it we've used it occasionally but
it's not our specialty but we
do have a rather deep history in fact we
learned from the best we learned from
arnold kluge who was philosophically so
deep
that we really got the full strength uh
introduction into what phylogenetic
systematics is and why it works the way
it does so let's just give two sentences
of explanation phylogenetics or
phylogenic systematics is the sort of
origin of species half of evolution
wherein we are trying to determine
relationships between species or in this
case variants of a virus as opposed to
the sort of sort of half of evolution
where we tend to spend more of our time
talking here which is at the sort of
population level
how do
how do excuse me characters or in the
case of viruses variants arise and what
kinds of selective pressures allow them
to actually expand in numbers in a
population or or recede and so
systematics being the sort of the
macroevolutionary side
can
can use a number of types of information
to build the trees and you know
historically and and kluge who was my
major advisor uh typically used
morphological characters uh like like
bone and muscle uh you can also use
developmental characters and then of
course the sort of molecular revolution
that began in the 90s
would seem to have overwhelmed uh the
use of other
slower two code characters like
morphological data sets
once sequencing came online and and
became cheap enough for people to do uh
in a lot of labs uh but really as we
learned from arnold's we learned from dr
kluge a total evidence approach in which
you which you look at data from all all
of the angles and look for consilience
between them is likely to be the best
yeah um
at some point we ought to have this this
conversation i i would not divide
the two evolutionary biologies as as
you've just laid it out i mean obviously
that is the traditional divide that
everyone everyone who's ted you know had
a week of evolution anywhere will have
heard macroevolution versus microbial
right but uh you know as you know i
uh differ with most of our colleagues on
the relationship between adaptation and
macroevolution so anyway
i think there's a better way to do it
and just for the from the point of view
of of our listeners and viewers
phylogenetic systematics is about
describing the tree shape itself what is
more closely related to what than what
else right the shape of the tree and
then the other part is the study of why
things look the way they do or function
the way they do and so just one more uh
for those of you who have read our book
chapter 2 of the 13 chapters does the
sort of deep history of what are the
changes uh that we think we know about
uh the lineage to which we belong the
three and a half billion
ish uh year lineage to which we belong
and so you know we have i think three
four five trees phylogenetic trees in
that chapter that describe uh you know
the current best understanding and
really you know we only included trees
where there's you know it's we're really
very very certain um that these are the
relationships yeah and at the you know
you as you zoom back out on a tree the
relationships become much more secure
right there are lots of very subtle
variations very in the you know nitty
gritty at the tips of the branches but
you know between big groups that they're
much clearer anyway zach did you find
the uh
uh if you click on the tweet
well people will get the gist
okay so what so actually this points out
in part why macroevolution might be the
wrong term because this is all
microevolutionary change so these are
all the variants that are being tracked
and the line what's the x i mean the x
axis is presumably time so when does it
start what's what's the left most uh
zach will have to read it i think it's
like mid-2020 or maybe it's early 2020
[Music]
2019.
yeah okay okay so it starts right at the
beginning of the sort of named pandemic
and what you have are all of the
variants and their relationships as
deduced by their sequence sequence
differences
and what you saw is that omicron
pops up uh
without any history of connection to the
rest of this swarm
uh as if it came about somewhere march
through
september of 2020. 2020 yes so it you
know 2021. omicron
no it shows up in 2021 but the point is
it's relationship it is as if it has
been frozen in time
uh at a much earlier state and then
shows up now the thing is this has
people over in lab league world
fascinated because this is not the first
time in history that this has happened
in fact there's a very famous example
that you may have just barely heard
mentioned in the lab league discussion
about the
flu of 1977.
and the flu of 1977 it has been
concluded this of course could be
revised if some better model emerged
that was more predictive or assumed less
but it has been concluded
for now and with substantial evidence
is actually a lab escapee and the way we
know that is that its closest relative
dates back to 1949. so it vanished from
the world
and then the clock started again on its
evolution in 1977.
so that indicated this surely was in a
fridge somewhere or isolated from the
world whatever was happening with it
effectively time was stopped and that
effectively requires a refrigerator in
an organism or a virus
that does not have extraordinarily
variable mutation rates
um you don't you you would not
you could not possibly expect a whatever
that would have been a 28-year hiatus
with no changes right and so the other
example that we have of this which isn't
as good because we don't really have a
good uh
ancestor right we is
is
sars kobe 2 itself where we suddenly
have a virus that's very very good at
doing the things virus needs to do in
order to become a human pandemic with no
history of circulating in another animal
where it learned those tricks no history
of circulating in some population of
humans as far as we can tell somewhere
it just it's a genius right off the it's
like a child that was born uh speaking
three languages or something you know
um
and so anyway this has people who are
paying attention to this thinking very
carefully about
what could even explain this other than
it having
been
somewhere in someone's lab
during the period of time that we would
have expected it to emerge and then
suddenly popping back up
and there are other anomalies too like
things like the um
the non-synonymous to synonymous
mutation
rate is way off of normal
it's like 25 to 1. so this is about how
many
alterations that have no consequence for
uh actual protein sequence you would
expect for everyone that has an actual
consequence and the number appears
impossible through a normal process now
what the discord server has asked us to
answer
is the question of well
could it be you know what
what might explain
this this variant with this many changes
uh appearing so suddenly given a
a supposed background rate of so many
people checking all the time for
variants right and so what i think we
should do rather than
search the world for crazy explanations
is just
identify
one so you've heard things like um
immunocompromised person
in which
much more evolution took place than
normal because their immunocompromised
state effectively created a gain of
function environment a serial passage
environment between tissues that was
extremely favorable to variants now this
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
because
um and in fact i think the idea so it
was originally reported that it had been
isolated from somebody with hiv and
diagnosed hiv i believe that that has
been debunked although who even knows
what debunked means in 2021
but uh nonetheless
these kinds of explanations have been
offered before in fact there was one
quite good paper i thought it was dead
wrong but quite good paper that argued
that it could be
that sars kovi ii
experienced extreme evolutionary change
in one of the miners who got sick in
yunnan province because lungs have such
a large surface area back in 2013. yeah
it was a very clever argument again i
think it's dead wrong but anyway it's at
least the kind of thought you would want
to have how could you get more evolution
than you expect right maybe surface area
is the answer well at least in that case
it it
you can track the story evolutionarily
like the logic each logical step is
plausible even if one
one or more of them may be so unlikely
as for it not to have happened so many
of these stories that are charted out
these these
explanations
that are you know thrown out at the
masses and then
and then the guy and effectively the
white lab coat steps out to say i know
you can't follow this so let me just
tell you the conclusion is um actually
just don't even logically hold together
and you know this
we've sort of
excuse me we sort of stopped
you and i have stopped largely coming on
here and saying oh this thing except it
doesn't make sense and this thing except
doesn't make sense because it's just
coming so fast and furious like this
i don't
on the face of it the idea that
immunocompromised creates gain of
function in a body i don't
i don't know why that would be true i
haven't i have yet to hear the
explanation for how you get from a to b
that's just a simple a to b
spell it out like well the idea the idea
to the extent it is an idea rather than
excuse is um in the immunocompromised
body the defenses that would ordinarily
silence lots of evolutionary experiments
in the body tolerates them
right something like that and so you
have it's like a big population in which
processes that wouldn't
make any headway in a small population
gets a chance
so if that is true yeah you would expect
that immunocompromised people would tend
to be incubators of uh of lots of
variations in colds other coronaviruses
or flus or you know any of the other
things it makes other predictions and
frankly i don't know whether any of
those predictions are manifest
um right the other thing that's how you
would actually follow this up with a
scientific approach the other thing
would be
okay so let's say that this is true in
the immunocompromised person and you get
lots of evolution of little
you know there are lots of foothills in
the immunocompromised person that don't
exist in people with a fully competent
immune system but then when the variant
gets out into people who do have a fully
competent immune system you wouldn't
expect those variations to function very
well
unless they only got a foothold because
of immune suppression right so then you
would need another step to the process
and the point is this is where you start
running afoul of occam's razor you're
not just you're not just hypothesizing
an immunocompromised person which
provides a unique environment you're
you've got another black box that you
need to fill and at some point it's too
many epic cycles to be sustained so i
would just i just want to point out the
other thing that we talked about last
week that fits this category is the
why did uh
why did covet 19 collapse in japan oh
yes after they allowed doctors to
prescribe ivermectin and the answer was
oh uh it became mutationally aggressive
and uh lost its coherence and it's like
it just did so well that it failed right
something and so the answer is no you
need at least one more factor you know
what one factor could do it ivermectin
could drive a virus to make some sort of
a deal that it couldn't sustain but you
can't do it just spontaneous mutational
idiocy
[Music]